We'll be speaking with doctor Robert
Levenson from the University of California
Berkeley,
who is going to be speaking with us
about this question that's guided much of
our discussion today. Blood
tears, sweat and fears,
the autonomic nervous system and emotion.
So doctor Levinson received his phd
from Vanderbilt University in clinical
psychology and he's currently a professor
in the Department of Psychology at the
university,
California Berkeley,
where he's a member of both the
behavioral neuroscience, clinical science,
developmental and social
personality programs.
He currently serves as the director of
the institute or personality and Social
Research as well as the director
of the clinical science program.
So Dr Levinson's research program is in
the area of human emotion studying the
Organisation of physiological,
behavioral, and subjective systems.
The way that these systems are impacted
by neuropathology normal aging and
culture and the role that emotions play
in the maintenance and disruption of
committed relationships.
Dr Levinson's research has been
supported by grants from the NIH and Nia,
and he is the past
president of the Society for
psychophysiological research and
the past president of the association
for Psychological Science.
So I now turn to a very special experts
in emotion interview with Doctor Robert
Levenson from the University of
California Berkeley. Welcome Bob.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Okay.
Yeah.
So what I wanted to start out asking
you a bit about is really what got you
first interested in the study of emotion,
kind of where did it all begin for you?
Well,
actually this is one of these questions.
Where are you normally have an answer,
but I remember the exact moment.
Uh hmm.
I just started my first faculty
position at Indiana University and um,
I had been in the field at that time
was dominated by a Dick Lazarus,
Richard Lazarus.
His work on sort of stress and coping.
It really wasn't a feel of
emotion. It was, it was a really,
it was going to be another six or seven
years before it started to explode.
And um, in this, in the
models of stress and coping,
um,
you got the idea that there was a sort
of a stress response and everybody did
the same thing. If you, if you, uh,
provoke them in your laboratory,
everybody would pretty much
have the same reaction.
And people before Lazarus,
like Han Celia had described
the physiology of that
response quite elegantly.
Um,
one of the things that we're starting
to come into the field was greater
reliance on video recording and um,
we had just run a classic
stress study where we had, uh,
threaten people with electric
shock and we had had them gifts,
a self revealing speeches about
their weaknesses and you securities
studies.
Yeah.
When I looked at these video tapes to
see the started fixed action patterns
where everybody was doing the same thing
and it was just the opposite though,
it's just this incredible variety
of response. It was complex.
If I'm folding it over time,
it changed over time for different people.
And some of it was quite counterintuitive.
This is gonna seem really dumb,
but the fact that people were laughing
when they were threatened with it,
it was real electric shock.
We actually shot them in those days.
You were allowed to do
that. Um, and, and you know,
it wasn't this sort of like general
negative stress response. It was,
it was this a rainbow of different,
different things that I realized that
this was very important and I have no idea
how to start again. I have no idea how
to measure it or quantify it. And, um,
and the behavior we only
deaf tied anything that I
could probably get at with a
self report measure or the physiological
measures that I was a news.
Right. So I, uh, I got interested
in that and, um, as a result,
I want to tell you the whole story,
but about three or four years later,
I was able to go,
come out to San Francisco to spend a
year working with these two crazy guys,
Paul Ekman and Wallace reason started
spent a decade focusing on how you measure
this very thing, you know, and, and, uh,
they were developing a coating system
or characterizing the full variety of
human emotional response. And so that's
how I got interested in. It's just,
it's just, it was compelling in, in the,
in what I was seeing that um,
something was going on here that was
much more differentiated than I expected.
Thank you for that.
I mean it's,
it's a really compelling story just by
observing a phenomena you saw something
that you didn't understand and that's
really what propelled all the research
that you're doing now.
And I mean really as a forefront
in this field of emotion as well as
psychophysiology. I mean, you do work
that inspires so many generations, um,
like myself and others to try to
continue to grapple with these,
these questions and phenomena that
we observe but we don't understand.
Well, I think that's the best
way to do research. I mean,
I know that's your last question
and we'll come back to it. Right?
You can over arching
research that's grounded in
fundamental curiosity about the
things that amaze and baffle you
is the research that, you know,
he's going to keep your interest
for a long period of time.
And I figure if you're lucky, you get, if
you, if you hit on good questions, it'll,
it will attract other people
through those issues. Um,
but curiosity is sort of at the core
of my sort of approach to research.
So I mean, when thinking about
curiosity, the realm of psychophysiology,
I mean you have really sort of taken
a lead in specializing in these really
complex, you know, psychophysiological
tools to study emotion. And I mean,
in your opinion,
sort of what do you see as some of
the most effective tools for trying to
understand and measure this really
complex? You know, rain boys, you call it,
of emotional responding?
Well,
I'm going to,
I'm going to give you an answer that's
probably a little strange change and that
is that I think the best,
the best psychophysiological
tools are good, are good,
inappropriate research
questions. Uh, that is, um,
what I was first getting
involved in psychophysiology. Um,
one of the,
the dominant voices in the field was a
fellow named Paul Brest who was working
in the Department of Psychiatry at
the University of North Carolina.
Could have been Duke. No,
that's an important distinction.
That range. Yeah. But he was
always you MC. That's where I was.
And he was a curmudgeon,
the guy and a
fighter and he um,
he also championed young people
who are working in the field.
And his mantra was we need to know more
biology to understand the biology of
these measures and had a huge
influence on me. And, and to this day,
um,
I almost tried to think
the art of psychophysiology
is to ask a question that,
that for which these
measures are appropriate. Um,
I can't tell you how many people write
notes when they're applying to graduate
school and say, I run, I want to
use these measures in athletics.
It's like measure first and then
if I get a chance to talk to him,
I only saw the same unless the question
and a lot of questions in psychology are
not appropriate for these
kinds of methods and measures.
So that's the first thing.
Good.
Psychophysiology is based on good
questions and a good understanding.
These are not psychological measures.
Dick biological measures,
they aren't measuring personality
and the aren't measuring emotion.
You're measuring metabolic processes.
And adjustment of the
homeostasis in the body and,
and how we mashed them into
the psychological question.
That's part of good psychophysiological
research. And I think it's really,
really difficult and it's,
and it's easy to have a
mismatch where the measure,
no matter how sophisticated,
you know,
how down to the millisecond the
accuracy and the no fault is, it's,
it can be the wrong measure for,
for psychological question and then you
just get nothing. So, so that's, you know,
that's, that's the prelude. Um, I
know that's not exactly what you were,
you were getting at, but, but then I think
the getting to the measures themselves,
I think the challenge has always been,
you know,
how can we get from the behavior of,
of these target organs, you know,
the heart,
lungs and whatnot to the underlying
action of the nervous system because we
really want to understand it in terms
of sympathetic and parasympathetic.
And within these, you know, Beta
and Alpha adrenergic subsystems,
we really want to get a sense of what
part of the nervous system is active. And,
and that has been an area where there's
been enormous progress over the last 20,
30 years.
It used to be that we could
measure what Oregon's we're doing,
but we couldn't really infer what the,
what the activating mechanisms were.
And that's been a real powerful tool.
And you only turns out that
w that changes in heart rate,
let's say that there that are instigated
by parasympathetic action, um,
now founded very different psychological
constructs and ones that are instigated
by a sympathetic action.
And so it would be able to get that kind
of underlying mechanism to be reveal,
you know,
in our psychophysiological measures.
I think that's been a
huge advance in terms of
getting to the real core of
phenomena like emotion, you know, or,
or you know,
attachment or these big psychological
constructs where the physiology,
you can actually tell us
some very interesting thing.
So when you think about really trying
to probe under my underlying mechanisms
further, where do you see some of the
next most critical steps in the field of
psychophysiology moving
towards to be able to do this,
to get at some of these really profound
processes you were hinting like emotion
attachment and then like,
well
I hope this isn't self serving.
Uh,
but it's really worth thinking
about in the last couple of years.
I mean I've been,
I mean we're only interested in the
sort of the numeric side of physiology.
Um, you know, my own work
going back for a long time,
I constantly gotten attracted to
the ways that sort of physiology is,
um, is it provides a
measure of contagion. Um,
and it provides a way of characterizing.
We have shortly connection between people
who are interacting and an emotion.
You know,
it provides a way of
looking at a coherence,
coherence between different
aspects of your emotional response.
So to answer your question,
I think the era of the
mean is probably over
Aaron. I see that we're going to
have to go back to the, we are oh,
your physiology, which either
it is a time series, it's, it's,
it's something that unfolds over
time and has [inaudible] and uh,
it does have changes in levels if
that's just part of that pattern.
And I think the challenges is going
to be finding ways to characterize
physiology over time,
how it relates to other unfolding
phenomena in the individual,
like their subjective experience and their
emotional behavior and how it sort of
operates when two people
are in and the interaction.
And so how you are physiology
and my physiology and the,
and the kind of temporal
relationships between them.
He was close to the kind of psychological
connection that we're engaged in.
So I think that's the next frontier
and it's ending, you know, it's,
it's really um, challenging. Um,
I mean going back to the last few months
and we reading all this stuff I read
when I was in graduate school about
things like time series analysis for
analyses and water retention and whatnot.
Him and try and sort of come up with that,
a fresh approach for characterizing
some of these temporal relationships.
So it's what's on my mind these days.
Yeah, I mean, so I'm
thinking about, you know,
some of the original groundbreaking
work you did here where you identified,
you know,
distinct patterns of autonomic nervous
system activity with particular emotion
states.
And on the one hand I wanted to ask
you sort of what do you see as the most
interesting discoveries
in that original work?
But what you're saying now makes me think
too sort of how can we move that field
forward of emotion specificity if
we're looking at these more dynamic
fluctuations and physiology over time.
That's what I'm thinking about.
I mean I I remember very clearly are used
to have a slide one slide and why I'm
jumping in one talk based on one emotional
elicitation in wanting individual,
it's actually two different emotions and
it was just looking at what happened to
heart rate,
second distraction when that person was
experiencing profound discussed versus
profound anger. And you know,
the differences were not,
oh you could see where the mean
differences came from. You know,
the fact that at the end of the day,
most of the time when you're angry,
your heart, it's going to accelerate
much more than when you're disgusted,
when you're disgusting, often decelerates
so you could see how you got there.
But the kind of the temporal path to
that was, was so different for these two,
for these two emotions and
in this one individual.
And you know how to characterize that
and doing it in a way that's meaningful
and not just descriptive, it's
in, can be scaled up to studies.
I think it,
I think that that is one of the really
important new frontiers in the study of
specificity.
And I think the same thing is probably
true if you're looking at the brain,
you know,
we really want to look at not only where
it ends up in terms of what the active
areas are,
but also how it got there.
And I think the brain people with
functional imaging to Barton much more
inclined to,
to work in that way.
Well, I mean, speaking of the brain,
I mean you've really uncovered some
additional fascinating insights about how
neurodegenerative diseases
like frontotemporal dementia
FTD profoundly impact,
you know, a whole host of different
emotional related processes.
Right from you've looked at perception
reactivity as well as regulation,
both spontaneous and queued.
And I wonder as you're thinking about
psychophysiology in this realm, you know,
at the realm of sort of neural
systems in neurodegenerative diseases,
sort of what were some
discoveries you came up, you know,
in doing this research where
they surprising to you. Um, what,
what sort of struck you in
working with this population?
Well, you know, we started
with the observation that,
you know,
here was a well characterized
neurological condition that was producing
something that looked very much like
psychiatric symptoms are not a real
clinical psychologist,
but I sort play one and my profession.
Yes you are.
I think one of the great gifts of graduate
training for me was being trained as
a clinical psychologist,
but how a pretty good sense of why your
clinical conditions and symptoms look
like.
And I was really struck with
these patients who didn't
have icebox Perry's and
you know, little birth away
and didn't have, you know,
a psychogenic kind of
factors in your life.
The thing we're producing,
these kinds of symptoms that they'd look
very much like psychiatric conditions.
Um, and so as is typical of my work, um,
I was just struck by that and
became very curious as to, you know,
how it was that, um, damage
to these neural circuits.
I mean,
now we understand that
it's not [inaudible] it's
[inaudible] markets that are
really producing these changes.
Could we produce things that mimic
these kinds of clinical phenomenon? Um,
and it seemed to me that it could
tell us a lot about emotion.
It could also tell us a
lot about emotion based.
And so th that back to me was the kind
of a striking, there's surprising,
it was just how powerfully,
uh,
these teasers produced these symptoms.
When I was in graduate school,
the chapter on brain damage was
always just about cognitive,
with the exception maybe of Phineas gage.
And that was such a terrible case
study. You know, who knew what happened.
But as a result,
I was skipped it when I taught like uh,
clinical psychology cause didn't have
anything to do with this emotion.
The West surprise me is that
there's this whole set of, of uh,
of January of neurodegenerative diseases
that actually are like a silver bullet
into the heart of our
emotional functioning.
We only under described under appreciate,
I'm getting better now this,
the misdiagnosis just like that,
you know, he just, we call it dementia,
which which suggest, you know,
problems in mentation and never memory,
but you know,
here's this other set of disorders.
They're really quite different.
And then of course the reason for
that is that they hit very bad effect,
very different kinds of
circuits in the brain.
So the exciting thing for me was here was
an opportunity to really study emotion
in the brain without the
constraints of the scanner. We,
we didn't have this like only study those
emotional things that could occur too.
We could do,
we get to study all the things that
happened in real life and linked them back
ultimately cause fairly well
characterized changes in the brain.
I just thought this was a great,
this was a great new playground.
What have you found,
you know,
in this research you've done with
this group of FTD patients and other
neurodegenerative diseases,
sort of what has it told you about the
role of the brain and sort of normative
emotion processing?
Yeah. Well, you know,
it's not a finished story.
I mean, you know, I, yeah,
it's kind of like a second,
like a second wind and in a career or
something, you know, it's like we started,
we started doing this work
about a decade ago and good,
good questions take decades to talk,
to lead to good answers.
And I sort of feel like
we're still mid stream. Um,
the thing that I'm really found myself
thinking about a lot and the people in my
lab also gravitating to and the people
we collaborate with and it's really
ironic,
is the role of sort of the subjective
emotional experience and particularly the
contribution of visual perception
and visceral sensations to,
to our emotional lives.
Um,
we've trained and because this disease
targets predict circuitry are critical
for the processing of this visceral
information. We think that the, uh,
kind of the interior emotional life,
if these patients
ooze kind of the visceral quality,
you know,
the butterflies in the stomach and,
and probably some of the cinematic
qualities like tensions and whatnot.
This sensors have the sensor coolness
and warm tingling on the skin that all of
these things that are really,
you know,
I think we're coming to
understand critical parts of
how emotion influences our
behavior,
um,
are probably being diminished
and muted by this disease.
And then when you see people don't
have this part of their emotions,
you begin to realize just how they are.
Um,
and it certainly has made my,
my normal emotion research much
more focused these days on this.
Your perception,
uh,
trying to find ways of characterizing
that and measuring it didn't have
historically a very difficult
problem with field. Uh,
how do you characterize the,
the extent of a visceral awareness and
how do you monitor it moment to moment?
Nope.
Yeah. So I mean this
is fascinating. I mean,
just thinking about where you first
began in this field, you know,
observing a phenomena that was mysterious
and exciting to being, you know,
forefront at the figure of the
field of emotion and as well as in
psychophysiological processes that,
that help us understand emotional related
phenomena and sort of having seen the
field of emotion evolve over time.
I guess sort of taking a step back,
where do you see now the face of
the future and emotion headed?
What lies ahead?
Well, clearly the headlights
ahead. I mean, you know, uh,
emotion started as being started, the
province and the autonomic nervous system,
uh, you know, the older
models where that, uh,
linked cognition and emotion were all
top down and show, you know, in the,
in the early views,
emotions were sort of these irritating,
nasty little things that had to be
brought under the control of rational
processes. And now, you know,
I think that there's any question that
in turned upside down,
but now almost all of psychology
seems to be a balance.
The influence of emotion on other things,
including a whole range
of cognitive processing.
Probably most famously how emotions
influence our decisions. Um,
and, and sometimes you know, cause us to,
to decide things or don't appear to be
rational by sort of western standards.
But really our rational in terms of
ar I sort of reptilian standard that's
embodied cognition is another area
where this is really okay. So I,
so I think that one,
one clear future direction is the way
is this is the bottom up directions,
the way emotions,
what do we shape our thinking are our
memories that we should stop that we've
played with in the past.
But I think there's a lot of
good work that's necessary.
Um, the secondary is clearly
emotions and close relationships.
Hmm.
I think attachment theory is one of these,
it's like as a Jamie,
the James Lang theory of emotion
on Bowlby's attachment theory is,
is it great idea
that really needs to be looked at with
modern two goals and they think the way
emotions function in making these
lasting emotional some days.
Last thing sort of interpersonal
bonds is really another critical area.
And then I think about the other one that
is kind of uh, interscape and is that
he grew up in an era where I think you
could say this is probably something
people would argue with.
I think you could make the case that
progress in to treat treatment of mental
illness and the understanding of it,
it's really hit a wall and that,
um,
both in psychiatry and in psychology is
really almost nothing significant in the
last decade or so.
It's made a huge difference in either
understanding or ability to treat.
We're recycling old ideas or there
are a few exceptions for that. You,
we don't know what will come with them.
Like deep brain stimulation
and things like that. Yeah,
very different approach. Maybe
something would come that. Uh,
so I think,
you know,
this is going to be a huge area
of growth in the coming decade.
You know,
really taking a fresh look at
emotion is notion dysfunction.
Um, in and to tobacco happened, a
number of things have to happen.
You're probably not going to have no
line is we have to do away with the DSM.
You have to go back to much more molecular
way of looking at the symptoms might
be,
are
we only clear out all of the,
um, the interference life from,
from the accreditation that chiefs of
progressive programs from we only training
their students and the way they think
they should be trained and we have to
learn how to talk to
now like psychiatrist,
but we have to with him talk to behavioral
neurologist and have a different kind
of understanding about the brain and,
and then sort of refocus on these issues.
I think that could be the most exciting
for the next generation. And I think,
you know, if we could get to
that point and just throwaways,
today's really the baggage or some
of the old systems and old ideas.
I think this could be the era of making,
you know,
we don't progress and understanding
and treating a mental illness.
So then we, we're thinking about
this next generation, right?
A big part of who is going to be at the,
our students right now.
So when the students come to you,
Bob,
and ask you for advice of
what they should do, um,
if you know wanting to embark in this
field of emotion, what do you tell them?
Okay,
wow.
Probably five things that you really
want to know a lot about our thing.
I think, why do you want to know if you're
gonna Spell your motion? You better.
You better learn how to observe behavior.
MMM hmm.
My opinion. Somebody disagree. You know,
most of the really exciting progress
in emotion has been made. Um,
at least kind of contact where people
directly observed emotional responding and
they had ways of quantifying it.
And you know, you can really,
you can really parse emotion research
into those who look at behavior and those
who don't.
So I think he needed need to
understand the behavior too.
You need to have a really
strong foundation in biology.
You don't understand the physiological
systems and increasingly these days that
includes a genetic systems
in different systems as well.
Um,
and then I think,
I think you need to understand
what emotion looks like when it's,
when it's operating within normal bounds.
And also when it's operating within these
sort of dysfunctional, abnormal values,
and we've all emotion researchers
need to have some exposure to emotion
pathology, whether it's a neural, uh,
but whether it's shut off by some sort
of neurodegenerative process or some sort
of psychological process,
which you really have to understand like
what emotion looks like when it's not
there blunted or when it's
when it's hyperactive.
And you need to see that
and understand that.
And so I think those are the
kinds of things, you know, that,
that good emotion researchers are going
to have to, to know. And, you know,
we don't train students that way, we,
so we sort of train them in silos.
So clinical students do this
and neuroscience students
do that and aspect of
science students, you
know, do something else.
But I think that good emotion research
is going to really require this behavior
biology and pathology.
Okay. Well, Bob, thank you so
much for speaking with us today.
Alright,
this huge room.
Nice to see you too.
Um,
this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Robert Levenson from
the University of California at Berkeley.